during Marvel Studios panel at San Diego
comic-con 2019 Avengers infinity war and
end game screenwriters Christopher
Markus Stephen McFeely revealed that
Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner was
initially meant to merge with his Mean
Green alter-ego the Hulk an infinity war
rather than in Avengers endgame
according to polygon Markus and McFeely
explained that one of the most difficult
things to get right was crafting the big
character moment where Banner finally
settles his differences with the Jade
Giant brings together his brain with the
Hulk's brawn arising a smart version of
the Hulk
the duo wanted the characters arc to
make sense with viewers easily
understanding the motivations behind and
methods of banners metamorphosis but it
turned out to be more complicated than
they initially thought as Marcus
explained the infinity war team wrote
and filmed the whole transformation
saying the achieved union with the Hulk
while inside the Hulkbuster he kicked
Cole obsidians
ass banner and Hulk becoming one while
wearing the Hulkbuster armor was such a
hit with the infinity war crew they
swiftly moved on to shoot Avengers end
game thinking everything was shipshape
and would be satisfying for fans but
Markus and McFeely found flaws in their
plan to introduce professor Hulk and
infinity war if it works it's gonna work
and you're gonna have a lot of chances
to find that out and if it doesn't work
we'll circle back around in their eyes
the magic of the Hulk Banner Union
subsequent buck kicking a black order
underling Cole obsidian faded fast and
they realized they absolutely couldn't
have that in the film Marcus said it
didn't work it was the wrong tone for
the movie a big sequence where you see
the union take away from the attention
of the story there was a big problem
though directors Joe and Anthony Russo
had already filmed Avengers end game
where banner and Hulk had merged so it
was reshoots to the rescue Markus and
McFeely reworked the endgame script
banner actor Ruffalo came back to set to
refilm some sequences and that the at
Racal cuts of infinity war was
permanently changed as fans will recall
Banner does indeed join his fellow
heroes to take down Thanos and his army
of aliens across the plains of Wakanda
and infinity war and yes he does where
Tony Stark's Hulkbuster armor because
banner had trouble bringing hulk to the
surface after his initial failed scrap
of Thanos at the beginning of the movie
following that tussle which resulted in
Loki's death Banner couldn't hold out no
matter
how hard he tried I'll be doing good
thank really really good really good you
plan on helping out time won't come out
banners are can Avengers infinity war
contradicted plot points teased in the
film's trailers one predominantly
featured Hulk in his full green glory
fighting side by side with Earth's
Mightiest Heroes after fans saw infinity
war on the silver screen and new Hulk
didn't show up during that final fight
it was believed that the clip shown in
the trailers were examples of Marvel
intentionally miss directing fans to
keep spoilers at bay with Markus and
McFeely recent reveal it stands the
reason that the clips of Hulk and the
infinity war trailers may have come from
before the big change was made smart
Hulk appears in Avengers endgame after
the five-year time jump from 2018 to
2023 the film offered a simple
explanation as to how the banner Hulk
Union happened banner spent 18 months in
the gamma ray lab before finding a way
to fuse his smarts with Hulk's strength
I put the brains and the Brawn together
and now they give me professor Hulk
shares the information with his Avengers
pals over breakfast where he washed down
pancakes and takes photos with young
fans mark is set at the moment an end
game a scene where Hulk eats a stack of
pancakes I've never seen that in a movie
well it would have been cool to see
Banner and the Hulk collide in infinity
war Markus and McFeely ultimate decision
to save professor Hulk for Avengers end
game makes more sense
it may have undercut a moment of
personal triumph or banner to follow it
with the snap both end game and infinity
war got rave reviews for their perfect
balances of action comedy and emotion at
the screenwriter stuck to their original
plan the reception may have been
different time travel oh my god what
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU were coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]